meagan Markel confirms this morning her
father will not attend her wedding to
Prince Harry
Markel said in a statement she hopes
Thomas Markel can be given the space he
needs to focus on his health final
preparations are underway this morning
in Windsor for Saturday's royal wedding
Roxana Saberi is in Windsor where some
spectators already camped out there's
perfect spot Roxana good morning good
morning it is the perfect spot well
despite the last-minute change
everything else appears to be going
ahead as planned this morning those who
are will make Saturday the spectacle
it's expected to be rode through these
streets in front of these fans warming
up for the big day two days until the
wedding everyone is getting ready for
the big day whether it's these young
coroner's excited to be singing for the
royal couple I'm really lucky because
not many people get to sing in such a
special event
[Music]
or troops rehearsing for the pomp and
circumstance of a military procession
some of these soldiers stood
side-by-side with Prince Harry on the
battlefield they'll soon be side-by-side
once more on his wedding day after the
ceremony at the chapel beyond these
castle walls members of the Armed Forces
will escort the bride and groom on a two
and a half mile carriage ride through
Windsor when these streets will be
filled with even more fans some of those
fans are already here saving a spot I'm
a crazy American in love with the Royals
Nancy McCoy flew in from San Rafael
California she's been sleeping on the
sidewalk since yesterday
just like she has for the Queen's past
to to Belize why was it so important for
you to come out here so early I know you
have to come early to get a good place
and I wanted to be right where the
carriage comes down I I considered the
long walk but I decided that this was a
better place it's going to come out
right here yes and then what are you
gonna do as for who will walk Megan down
the aisle now that her father can't make
it
odds are it will be her mother she has
flown in from California and is set to
accompany Megan here to the chapel on
Saturday or who knows Megan could walk
down the aisle on her own
John Roxana Saberi in Windsor thanks I
don't think they're gonna leave that to
the last minute the walking down there's
a plan in place I heard people
speculating that it may even be Prince
Charles I doubt that will happen but
that would be quite something to we'll
be watching you early you're right here
on CBS right here and that amping out
and Yale will have it all for us